[Music]
let's go to mac in loveland colorado
what's up mac
hey how you doing good brother how are
you man
i'm all right all right so what's up
dude
um
i need help kind of
figuring out
uh if and then
maybe where i'm being too hard on
my wife and our relationship and
what makes you think you're being too
hard
um
[Music]
some of it is whenever we have
conversations specifically about
harder stuff
more serious things what's harder
when it comes to what our family looks
like moving forward
in regards to
[Music]
kids where we want to live stuff like
that or even just
any hard topics that come up in the
world just naturally
i i like to talk about those things
and sometimes i feel like i might force
them on to her but she tends to
shut down not talk about things and
push them away or at least that's how it
feels to me and i don't know if i'm
putting her in a position to do that
and on top of that our relationship just
kind of
feels like it's been rocky since we've
been married okay
well i'll just start the call with
saying thank you for being brave man
that's a hard
phone call to make have you told anyone
else that you're struggling with this
uh yeah so my friends okay what do they
say
um
depending on the topic you know
it sometimes you know depending on the
friend turns into a
you know kind of comparing thing about
relationships and i try to stay away
from those and then some of them tell me
that you know things will work
themselves out and when things move
forward like you know with kids for
example that you know people just kind
of be able to step it up because they'll
have to and
i kind of get a little bit of everything
and so that's why i don't really know
where to go yeah i appreciate the trust
man
um so when your wife shuts down
um
when she shuts down
and you ask her about it what does she
say
um
not a whole lot i mean that's kind of
part of the problem is he shuts down and
there are times where i know that i get
a little too frustrated for it and not
in like an i'm yelling kind of way it's
just i'm clearly frustrated and i'm
i've been trying really hard to
recognize when it's happening and take a
step back
and maybe come back to it later but even
when i don't do that it still just feels
like it goes nowhere
words don't come out
and it just becomes like this like
circular conversation
what's what's what's your goal for the
conversation are you really trying to
get to hey let's go ahead and nail down
how many kids we want to have or where
do we want to live or is is this your
way
of
trying to be intimate
trying to connect
um
i would say
both but probably more towards the like
actually trying to figure things out
okay
you all been married two years how old
are you
i'm 27. okay
uh when i was 27 we were gonna have four
kids and i was cool at stopping with
three
and we were gonna live probably in
houston texas
was my guess
and now i've got two kids we're done and
i live in nashville
never not even on the radar
and so what is your
what is your impulse to try to nail this
down why do you need this nailed down
right now at 27.
i don't even necessarily want to say
nailing it down it's
i just want to be able to talk about
some of these things and it seems like
we can't like like it kind of started at
first as she's getting ready to turn 30
and so it's you know doing the whole
like i'm 30 30 and getting old kind of
thing and i've got seven gray hairs and
that kind of thing has been going on and
then it's turned into i'm you know on
like she's brought up you know i'm on a
timer now with the whole baby thing and
we gotta think about this and for me i
i more want to make sure that our
relationship is strong enough to where
when we bring a child into the world
that it's in a good place that's the
best place that i can make it
what is that what does that look like
um
you know a strong
a strong family between her and i i know
but be very specific what's a strong
family between her and i because here's
what i here's what i hear just in your
language
is very amorphous
and some of that may be because you're
nervous on the radio but but it it's
very
the way you communicate even with me is
is somewhat circular and somewhat
amorphous
okay
just even the way like um tell me about
hard things you know just things that
we're talking about what our families
might family might look like down the
road when
instead of saying how many kids are we
gonna have and where we're going to live
and what she wants to do as a career you
see what i'm saying like one of those is
very direct here's what i'm trying to
get answers to
and i can imagine if somebody's hinting
around hey i'm 30
and i'd love to have a family with you
and we've been married for two years and
you're like well
i kind of have this
thing about what the
it's gonna look like and i want to make
sure we're strong
that's telling her
i'm still trying you out
and i don't have any clear criteria for
you
my guess is she has learned to shut down
she that's usually a behavior people
pick up in their childhood
but it is a futile
like this conversation will go nowhere
and will have no bearing
on there's nothing i can say in this
conversation that's going to have any
impact on my life whatsoever except
possibly negatively so i'm out
okay
and
i don't know what you're waiting for or
what kind of metric i've got friends in
my life that's like i wanted to have x
number of dollars in the bank before i
had a kid that was a security blanket
for me i wanted to to have this level of
position at a job until i realized every
job is fungible and the higher up the
latter you go the more likely you are to
get fired i don't know anything like so
i i had all these imaginary things
but it was pretty clear
here's when we're gonna start having a
kid my wife and i weren't trying out
right we wanted to both be done with
grad school we both wanted so we had
some very clear metrics it doesn't sound
like you have those
you just have this idea that i kind of
wanna
am i wrong
um
kind of just maybe just a little bit
nervous because okay i'm calling in
that's cool and that's totally fine
totally fine
some of it specifically is you know her
and i
were maybe intimate
once every two or three months and we're
only two years in and it's been that way
practically since we got married okay
and
i try to talk with her and figure out
what's going on with that
there's a thing that always
not always uh it comes up frequently
okay where she
kind of gets in her own mind and she's
told me this so this isn't like me
saying it
where she gets in her own mind she
essentially like catastrophizes a lot of
things specifically like death and
freaks out goes into a spiral she's
woking me up in the middle of the night
like crying and bawling and i'm like i
don't know i wasn't trained for this um
so like there's things like that and i
think a really big thing that
i may be conflating the two things but
it's also trying to figure out i
she went through a lot when she was
younger with her family
and
i
am worried that it's kind of affecting
things now and that it could affect
our family going forward so let me tell
you both of you both of you went through
things as a child
that is affecting your relationship
right now
100 chance yes
the only question you have moving
forward is
are we two gonna work together
to heal from what was and create
something awesome
moving forward create something new
create something strong create something
beautiful create something of our own
devising moving forward
that's the only question you have
and the answer to some folks is no
i'm going to live in the past i'm going
to always be this person who is abused
traumatized neglected left whatever the
word is
that is gonna be who i am
and then unfortunately you as somebody
married to that person have to decide
is this the life i'm signing up for
am i gonna just ride this one out
or am i out of here
or
the other side is we're gonna we're
gonna change everything
have you said hey i wanna go see a
counselor together
yes okay and she said no
um she just said yes
the problem our biggest problem is
scheduling but that's just an excuse um
100 actually do it 100 excuse me
and so what you can do is take the lead
because this sound like
the shutting down thing and the being
hard thing that what it sounds like is a
house filling up with pressure of
frustration
she's frustrated at how she responds and
how she feels because she wants to feel
different as your husband i mean as your
wife and she wants to feel different as
ex and wants to feel different it's why
and you want to experience this you want
to experience that and
none of that is happening
and you're walking and talking past each
other and you're living past each other
you're only having sex two or three
times i mean two once every two or three
months
um
and you're frustrated by that she's
frustrated by that and then all of a
sudden
it's because baby becomes the issue or
where we're gonna live becomes the that
becomes the volcano but man it's been
churning underneath
here's the frustrating part all you can
fix on planet earth is you
that's it yes
and so if i'm you
i'm gonna go sign up for my own
therapist asap
okay
i'm gonna go say i'm gonna start dealing
with me
i'm gonna start going to the gym
i'm gonna start doing these things to
for me to be healthy and me to be well
on me to be whole
i'm gonna get a job that i actually feel
like i'm right i'm gonna start doing
these things and every time i'm gonna
invite my wife along
i'd love for you to join me i'd love you
to come be a part of this
right is that fair yes no that's fair i
guess
how and i know i can't obviously force
her into doing anything but how can i
maybe ask her
to
get help with me or you know alongside
me or something like that with
stuff that she's been through because
that's kind of
it all kind of seems to go back to
something she went through when she was
younger and still connected to
specifically
to keep it as friendly family family
friendly as possible hey we're way past
that on this show dude we're way past
that
fair enough um her dad isn't her
biological dad when she was eighth or
ninth grade went to prison for the rest
of his life for recording himself with
children his niece okay and
so her dad her dad was a pedophile
yes and mentioned her in a recording and
she
says nothing ever happened with her
but that's kind of was her starting
point and she still talks to him on the
phone he is still
abusive to her like every time she gets
off the phone with him
i just hear it in her voice and i try
talking to her about it and then it
turns into well i thought you weren't
going to get like i thought you weren't
going to make it no you were my dad and
it's like
right so here's the way forward there
if you have a conversation in that right
at the end of that phone call you're
talking to somebody who's in such
escalated fight or flight there is no
conversation happening there there's
survival only
there's a conversation to be had that
says hey i'm gonna make breakfast on
saturday we're gonna do this one at home
and
um
i'm i want to tell you some things
i'm not going to ask you for your
response in any of these things but i've
got some things that have been on my
heart and in my chest and i want to tell
you
how many times would i try that because
i've
tried that a few times i think one time
i'd write a letter
okay and i would read the letter and i
would leave it with her
and when you start to have this
conversation she may shut completely
down not hear a word you're saying just
try to survive
she's had to survive her whole life
in that letter if she'll go back to it
and go back to it and go back to it
she'll see this man's different and this
man loves me
this man sees me and this man wants me
to be whole
and you get to she'll get to choose
moving forward
ultimately she's gonna have to decide i
want to get well and a wellness journey
for her is gonna be hard and you have to
convince her that i'm gonna be right
here with you
but yeah i can do that i can imagine
she's got
sex and intimacy for her is
war it's terror
right it's hard
probably yeah
and she may not even know that
or it's disgusting because it was used
as a way to hurt children you know
there's a million different ways her
body can take that all that to say is
this is gonna be the definitive
conversation i need you to get well
i can't hear that man's voice in my home
i don't want him calling our house
and if you need to talk to him
more than me then i'm gonna have some
hard conversa i'm gonna have some hard
decisions to make because every time
this man calls and talks to my wife she
gets hurt all over again
and i love you too much to
does that make sense i love you too much
to let you continue to talk so
negatively about yourself here
i guess i'm worried that that's going to
be an ultimatum and i'd
what's your alternative man
just keep floating along like you are
look up and it be five years from now
and she's more withdrawn and y'all have
had sex four times in five years i mean
what's the what's the alternative
i mean that and that's i guess what i'm
scared of and why i really wanna
where this usually ends
is in ash in
resentment somebody ends up running into
a co-worker that makes their heart beat
a little bit faster
or they find some websites that make
their heart fee beat a little bit faster
or they start working 130 hours a week
and make themselves busy
or they have one more drink and one more
drink
because when our relationships aren't
whole there's an entire ecosystem that
will take that pain from us and just
distract us distract us distract us
distract us
i'm not telling you to make an ultimatum
but you're going to get there at some
point i will not accept x and i will
accept y
the the
the faster you can get there the more
peace you're going to have because right
now it's just this ambiguous yeah i
don't know i don't you know what i mean
i don't know it's kind of
the more you live there the more your
body is trying to solve it solve it
solve it solve it solve it solve it
i guess i'm just scared to be specific
because of where it could lead and
scares the crap out of me i get totally
get that
but just know this the ambiguity's
killing you
and the ambiguity is killing her too
because she doesn't want your
relationship to be where it is either
so some specificity it's like when
people are getting out of debt
and they know they owe a bunch
it's like dude you gotta write down how
much you owe somebody
or when people's eating is out of
control like mine has been the last
couple of months
i
my dr norton my buddy lane gave
he said dude i've got the best
product on the market and just start
measuring what you eat dude i had that i
had that app
for a while before i had the courage to
start going like all right i gotta just
start and dude i didn't like it i
haven't i i've loved the app i've not
liked the
reality of my eating habits
when my wife sits down we have budget
conversations i don't like the reality
of my spending habits but their reality
right and so that specificity helps us
have a starting point and right now you
guys are just living in this amorphous
tension and when you live in the
amorphous you both default to
the things that your body knows hers
knows to withdraw yours knows to try a
little bit harder and have a different
conversation
and those aren't working
and so at some point we have to say
here's the status of our relationship
we've slept together three or four times
the last year
every time the pedophile calls our home
and i know he's your dad
you feel like this every time i want to
talk to you about the future this
happens
and i need something different
i need you
and i'll be a part of your healing
journey this can be hard but yeah i
think specificity is really important
this in this season
what do you need and what does she need
and how can you help each other get
there